un match pour l'histoire petit poucet de
la coupe de france de football édition
2021 2022 le club de bréval longue qui
évolue en dernière division
départementale jouer son destin face aux
vins c'est noah c'est aux sept divisions
plus haut c'est un vrai honneur pour
pour le club le petit renne le petit
club connaît la petite ville et
aujourd'hui on se retrouve on est là au
5 au quatrième tour et c'est une vraie
fierté pour nous malgré l'écart sur le
papier entre les deux équipes préval a
voulu jouer sa chance jusqu'au bout là
on doit tout donner et mon équipe n'a
pas le niveau d'un petit poucet donc je
pense que il ya moyen de faire de
grandes choses faut jouer la gagne ça
son cd joueurs ils ont deux bras des
gens comme nous il faut y aller c'est la
gagne au bout il ya que ça qui compte
façon que des gars et son terrain
aujourd'hui pour nous ce qui est
important c'est pas prendre de but dans
le premier quart d'heure faut qu'on se
donne les moyens d'y croire on sait que
ça est difficile tenir le plus longtemps
possible dans un stade où le public
était présent pour pousser les joueurs à
l'exploit on sent vraiment un engouement
autour de cet événement là on a bataillé
pour arriver jusqu'ici donné en trois
matches et c'est vrai que là aujourd'hui
on sent que tout le club est derrière
nous tout le village même on peut dire
donc on espère faire honneur aux
supporters qui m'ont vient nous voir
c'est historique pour eux valent donc
franchement c'est bien on est content de
représenter les couleurs de ce club coke
et je serai fier de mes joueurs s'ils
donnent tout porté par la foule et les
maillots blancs de la coupe de france
bréval a su contenir les attaques 20
seynoise jusqu'à la toute fin de la
première période
un but juste avant la pause qui
n'atténuera pas les espoirs breva loi
mais réduit à dix en fin de match ils
vont encaisser un second but dans les
dernières minutes
une défaite donc 2 à 0 qui sonne presque
comme une victoire tant les sept
divisions d'écart ne se sont pas
remarqué sur le terrain